what is happening reject nation it's
Greg Alva here I just got back from the
gym and I saw a bunch of notifications
about the mother trailer dropping early
it's supposed to drop August 8th maybe
in some different time zones outside of
California that's what they meant
Midnight's drop here in California early
so let's check it out and heads up paid
for the day shout out totally jumbled I
have a specific message for you we spend
all her time here I wanna carry you so
much older different older with less
detail when she breaks the life back
into everyone here not for long not for
long nipple to please Oh Harris change
her pressure canola and sweetener oh
hello hello show fibers immediately
[Music]
[Laughter]
music screaming at Unity place what were
you doing in their luggage how come
you're not questioning god help you in
on it your people new idea what the hell
is going on together just never enough
mother exclamation mark I'm excited to
see that movie love Darren Aronofsky's
work I'm excited to see him doing a
straight-up psychological horror film
man what a crazy story like get out but
with white people sort of that's quite
an intriguing trailer because now I just
want to know what the hell is really
going on the age gap difference I don't
know what it actually is between
Jennifer Lawrence and Javier Bardem but
I'm assuming he's a lot older than her
that kind of threw me off a little bit
first but it is not really a big deal a
lot of times you see movies about a
couple uninvited guests come in and
normally it's like they're just being
tortured by the uninvited guests come to
find out Javier Bardem he's kind of just
in on this and seems like he's in on
this the whole time the moment when she
says they had a photo of you and all he
says is what were you doing going
through their bag like he's questioning
her not questioning them there seems to
be some type of satanic devilish type of
cult happening here one thing Darren
Aronofsky does so well is the emotional
turmoil the deterioration of someone's
mind and how that plays out in a visual
aesthetic through their perspective and
point of view but it doesn't seem like
this is all just in Jennifer Lawrence's
mind I I don't think so I feel like
there's actual supernatural crap going
down inside of her home this film feels
very eerie feels very claustrophobic
I had terrifying nipple chill the entire
time feels a little bit like get out
meets Rosemary's Baby with a little bit
of like Antichrist vibes but of course
with the classic Darren Aronofsky
voyeuristic approach to the Luke's leads
to taking different looks like she's
given a powerful performance in this
film I'm interested to see more of what
ed Harris and Michelle Pfeiffer do or
their rules that are both good at being
creepy and I feel like I may be sneaking
way too early about this because I
haven't seen the film yet with a
director like Darren Aronofsky stars
like Jennifer Lawrence
ed Harris Javier Bardem love is their
oscar caliber people it would be so cool
if this horror film gets Oscar
consideration assuming the film is
really good of course or movies don't
really get recognized at the Oscars and
I feel like films like split get out and
now this this could be an even better
year for horror than it was last year
and can't wait for the Commons to roll
in about how Twitter has been attacking
Jennifer Lawrence and blaming her for
her spread and Anna Faris breaking up I
don't know anything about that but I
know Twitter has been going crazy over
that but I don't really care about that
I think she's going to do a great job in
this movie I just know that that was
gonna be comments coming in they said
they would debut this trailer before
that announcement was made I don't want
to get into the personal life Bertie's
gonna do it enough like three ended up
like this yeah this home looks really
cool I'm excited for it looks eerie
looks creepy
performances look great direction like
this yeah whoo oh yeah and before this
is done shout out to totally jumbled you
earned your picture of the day shout out
this month my friend and instead of
saying something funny I just want to
say why am you reply back to me on
patreon I sent you a message about the
Google hangout why haven't you replied
back to I really have to go to a YouTube
video sacrifice giving you a fun-filled
shout out to call you out being like
you're not responding to me that's not
the kind of relationship we have totally
jumbled your wife has a baby along the
way is that the kind of father you're
going to be someone who ignores people
you can't intellect your child you're
neglecting me it's going to start with
your child get it together
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification now follow me on Instagram
and Twitter real rejects on social media
platforms blah blah blah patreon bye